ich persönlich hatte ja im stillen
gehofft herr erdogan bricht sich
irgendwann wieder aber das muss man so
hart sagen der türkische präsident ist
inzwischen wirklich genau sowas wie ja
wie ein verhaltensauffälliger
jugendlicher wir kriegen mich
eingefangen kein anderer staatschef weiß
wie man mit so einem umgehen soll
liege ich um mit einem der sich benimmt
wie ein auffälliger jugendlicher ich
leite die fahrer weiter an carolin
kebekus die in köln ostheim ehrenamtlich
mit verhaltensauffällige jugendliche
arbeitet ja das ist eine sehr gute frage
ich gebe ja regelmäßig seminare hier um
die ecke im kino institut für
deeskalation forschung und die goldene
regel lautet wie er durch brauchen klare
ansprache
konkret wenn der erdogan die merkel
beleidigt soll die dann zu prügeln oder
volver erdogan ist erst da was wir in
der verhaltensforschung einem totalen
voller sie nennen
da geht es immer nur um respekt wie auf
dem hügel einmal schwäche zeigen aber
das heißt ja nicht dass man sich vom ton
her auf seinem niveau begeben
richtig sie kommen ja auch schön
austeilen
ich sage mal ganz ehrlich deutschland
verhält sich gerade wie das aller letzte
opfer psychiatrisch betreut aber
typische minister dürfen pro team weiter
bei uns reden so warm ist sowohl als
auch gelaber auf bestrafen musst du dich
für einige entscheiden entweder mit
meinen quer über den platz
türkei oder holland wird das für
krone.at
das regt mich so auf diese schule tour
und wenn wir deutschen meine türkische
propaganda veranstaltung verbieten dann
ernsthaft wegen brandschutz oder wien
parkplatzmangel mancher ort und online
hna.de konnten leider die kinderland
widersprechen die haut meist seine
tagesform aber wenn wir es machen wie
die holländer dann helfen wir doch auch
wieder erdogan propaganda welche wir
senden signale der schwächeren kinder
habe ich früher auch immer als ich hier
aufgewachsen bin
die haben mir jede woche die jacke oder
die schuhe abgezogen weil ich kraft
genug war
heute geben die mir ihre schuhe rosmarin
fuhr sie brauchen wir gar nicht aber es
geht ums prinzip
ich kann mir den erfolgen wir sollen den
türken die schuhe klauen kann im
übertragenen sinne natürlich auch um
ihren ohren geflogen
carolin kebekus schön
[Applaus]